live from the world's most famous arena
we're hearing from people who are
starved of playoff basketball
for eight years and they're taking out
all their energy right here and right
now
no no no no this is new york knicks town
exactly right
how you gonna do it if you really don't
wanna dance by standing on the wall
get your ass off we have a lot of money
in the game tonight but uh
how much probably like 300. they said
that's a lot of money
you know they regretting not coming to
the knicks they said it wasn't cool to
be a nick
but the whole city is only talking about
the new york knicks they're giving away
free tickets on that side we're paying a
thousand dollars each for ours
brooklyn is struggling to sell tickets
they're handing them out for free
and it's a nick city i got a tattoo on
my back of john stark come on
number three wow yeah look at that that
is a work of art
that below i could tell that's yeah that
looks custom for sure go new york
go new york go new york welcome to
player basketball baby
trey young i'm your father
i am your father trey young what are you
listening to right now
right now i'm listening to no music i'm
just got my headphones in so
nobody will bother me frapping means
it's about to be a gutter war
right we're about to take it to the
streets atlanta doesn't want this smoke
who the hell cares about atlanta anyway
wow unbelievable for the man with the
spray tan new york is a special place
when the knicks are in the playoffs
i'll tell you that brooklyn brooklyn
come on say that a lot of hipsters are
mad